hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one matter to which lev shestoff devotes
a lot of discussion
in all things are possible is what we
can
lump under the rubric of creative
activity what it is
that people who are really thinking
things through or taking
experience and making something of it
and producing
creative work in a broad sense are
are actually engaged in and how it
differs from the
public imagination of it and
we should keep in mind that that chest
off himself he talks about a lot of
creative people
in here a lot of authors for example
many of which are from russian
literature many of which are from from
other
nations literature as well and he
includes philosophers
among them particularly philosophers
like nietzsche but chester himself
is also a creative person
and the kind of philosophical work that
he does
is intense and anti-systematic
it's aphoristic he writes in
passages rather than trying to come up
with a total
system and so in a certain way he's
exemplifying
some of what he's talking about here
and from in my view the the most
interesting part and i think he's
completely right about this
is where he's talking about the
difficulties and trials
and uncertainties of engaging in
creative work so in chapter 42
for instance he has this
wonderful discussion he talks about
people say the raptures of creative
activity
empty words invented by men who never
had an
opportunity of judging from their own
experience who derive their conclusions
syllogistically
if a creation gives us such delight
what must the creator himself experience
and so
you know the idea is those who are
closer to the the creative work
will even more enjoy the creative work
it's sort of like saying
you know we might talk about chefs for
example and say wow this dish
tastes so wonderful it must be a joy to
prepare it and sometimes it is and
sometimes it's complete drudgery
and sometimes you have to you know start
again and throw away
ingredients and you're thinking in your
head well there just went 20 bucks
and so it's not quite the same
as the outside public has it and really
if you think about the ways in which
creative activity
is portrayed in movies and television
and sometimes even in literature those
are crazy ideas as well
you know you you can't just do a montage
and suddenly have a wonderful
thing to show people right so what is it
really like he says usually the creator
feels only vexations
every creation is created out of the
void
at the best the maker finds himself
confronted with a formless
meaningless usually obstinate and stiff
matter which
yields reluctantly to form when we're
doing genuine creative things we do have
some sort of matter that we're working
with think about wood carving
for example you have the wood and the
wood has a certain grain
and then as you're beginning to carve it
you find out that
it has certain inconsistencies and
splinters come off and it resists
us same thing with with clay it's never
perfect same thing
with you know imagining something and
then wanting to put it down on paper
in drawing or writing we have an idea
and we're like oh this is a great idea
i've got to put this out there this is
going to be so helpful for people
and as you're doing it even your
thoughts
sometimes resist and you're working
oftentimes without models because if
you're relying totally on models
you're not creative you're just sort of
replicating what other people have done
so he says every time a new thought is
gendered so often must that new thought
which for the moment seem
brilliant and fascinating be thrown
aside as worthless
and here's where we get to the real crux
creative activity is a continual
progression from
failure to failure and the condition of
the creator is usually one of
uncertainty
mistrust and shattered nerves the more
serious
and original the task which a man sets
himself the more tormenting
is the self misgiving as soon as one is
working with important stuff one becomes
conscious
at least if you're not just a you know
complete egotist or
solipsist or somebody who's full of
themselves
who's not going to produce good work
anyway usually
unless they're blessed with some
incredible raw talent which won't get
developed of course
if you're a what we might call a normal
creator you become aware
of the magnitude of what you're trying
to take on
you become aware that what you're doing
if it is successful
only represents one perspective on
something that's going to be
quite complex and so he says you know
there's a temptation here
this goes actually into those sort of
you know mistaken ideas and inferences
part
he says every connoisseur of art is
satisfied as
if he recognizes in a new work the
accepted manner of the artist few
realize that the acquiring of a manner
is the beginning of the end
artists realize well enough and would be
glad to be rid of their manner which
seems to them a hackneyed affair
he who has been through the creative
raptures is not easily
tempted to try again many will just keep
churning out the same thing
whether we're talking about music or
we're talking about you know cultural
criticism
or we're talking about installations
and at a certain point we could be like
oh yeah that's another one of this
person's things i i don't even have to
like
look at it i know what direction they're
going in and the creative process has
been
lost he's got another really great
description
of the creative person in chapter two
of part two he says that
here we go this is really great
to think really to think surely this
means relinquishing logic it means
living a new life it means a permanent
sacrifice of the dearest habits
tastes attachments without even the
assurance that the sacrifice will bring
any
compensation anytime that you're
engaging in real creative activity
whether it be artistic or philosophical
you are taking risks and he says
artists and philosophers like to imagine
the thinker with a stern face
a profound look which penetrates into
the unseen and a noble bearing an eagle
preparing for
flight so that's the common
representation
and obviously he doesn't mean all
artists and all philosophers
because some of these artists and
philosophers are themselves creative
people
who are engaging in thought so what does
a thinking person really look like
this is a wonderful description
a thinking person is one who has lost
their balance in the vulgar
not in the tragic sense hands raking the
air feet flying
face scared and bewildered a caricature
of helplessness
and pitiable perplexity why
because they don't actually know what
they're doing
and they they realize that they realize
they're out of their depth
when they get into anything that really
matters
something that has profundity to it
something that
is complex something that's close to the
life that we're living
and not just facsimiles of it they are
out of balance
and yet they still have to try to do
something so they're
they're wandering around off balance
right
now sometimes that off balance can be
turned into something useful
we might use the example here of the
fencer who engages in a flesh attack
where you literally place yourself off
balance so you can run at your opponent
and try to cut or stab depending on what
weapon you're you're using
and take them by surprise right but it's
a risky maneuver
it leaves you vulnerable to getting hit
in the back
as you go past them and you might
collide with them
who knows what's going to happen right
there is really
no method for becoming creative and he
has a discussion
in 2.5 about whether it's possible to
produce poets using poets as sort of the
stand-in
for the creative person he says
certainly we cannot make a child a poet
by forcing him to study literary models
from the most ancient to the most modern
neither will anyone hear us in america
no matter how loud we shout here
because americans are always given to
methods right to make a poet
of a person they must not be developed
among ordinary lines maybe books should
be kept from them
maybe it's necessary to perform some
apparently dangerous operation on a
fractured skull throw them out of a
fourth story window
i will refrain from recommending these
methods as a substitute for pedagogy
and he says but that's not really the
point you cannot
make a poet by some sort of
method or techniques so
a little bit later on he has a really
interesting
set of reflections in the next chapter
chapter six of part two
he talks about um the poet uh
you know until the apollo until apollo
the god of poetry
calls him to the sacrifice the poet is
plunged in the cares of this shoddy
world right
and he says pissarrev the critic was
exasperated by these verses
if they'd not belong to pushkin all the
critics would have condemned them
and then he says but this is actually
quite true you know
the poets can get into all sorts of
trouble
and not just mischief but corruption and
degeneration
when they're left to their own devices
you know it's not a matter of if we want
to be great writers or great thinkers
that we should simply
be virtuous people and always you know
rise early in the morning to practice
our craft as if life was a bunch of
life hacks you know that you can get
from some listicle
in in some website right people like
that don't know
anything about creativity and and it
shows in their works which are usually
garbage
just regurgitated tips and tricks right
people who are going to show real
profundity are probably not going to be
best sellers or if they are
most of the people purchasing the book
will bring it to the beach
and read it for a little while and put
it down but that's not what really
matters is it
so we have to realize that the
the really creative person is probably
going to be
kind of a a mess kind of a
chaos does that mean that then you
should like deliberately go out
and hang around bars and you know stay
up all night and
you know get into all sorts of weird
practices
that's not going to automatically make
you a poet and i you know but personally
i've seen so many people
who thought that just because they were
living on the cd side of life
that somehow that was turning them into
creative people when really they were
just
you know slowly degenerating but this is
something that is that is quite
important there's
the way in which we picture creative
work is
quite different than what somebody
living it's actually goes through
there's some other mistaken ideas and
inferences
he's got this great discussion about
what happens you know the old saying
that you don't want to meet your heroes
well he he talks about that
so mistaking the writer for the person
this is nearly at the end of the work
in chapter 42. he says people who read
much must always keep in mind that life
is one thing
literature another not that authors
invariably lie there are writers who
rarely and most reluctantly
lie but one must know how to read and
that isn't easy
so what's an example of this he says
it's a common belief that any writer who
sings of suffering
must be ready at all times to open his
arms to the weary and heavy laden this
is what the readers feel like when they
read his books
then when they approach him with their
woes and find that he runs away without
looking back at them
they're filled with indignation and they
talk about the discrepancy between
word and deed and this is you know
quite silly on their part whoever told
them that just because somebody writes
about something
that that's what their life is focused
on
you know you might as well go to a logic
textbook writer
and you know accuse them of being
illogical in their daily life because
they don't follow exactly
what they set out in the textbook there
are many people who write about things
and they've done research on them but
that doesn't mean that that's
what their life is all the time and it's
foolishness
to believe that or expect that
and we we you know lend ourselves to
these sorts of silliness things
for example you read kant and then you
read the little accounts of kant
walking at regular times so that people
could set their watch by him and you
imagine this character
and then you find out that he was
actually at bon vivant at dinner parties
and wrote about that
in i mean you can find it in his work he
actually laid out rules for dinner
parties
in his anthropology from a pragmatic
point of view and then you're like
whoa this is a totally different person
or at least not totally different but
quite different well whose fault is that
it's yours for being credulous
about literature and its connection with
with life
he also talks about how authors can
sometimes fool themselves
he says and this is quite true that
literature
deals with the uh here he goes in
chapter 28
literature deals with the most difficult
and important problems of existence
quite true as a matter of fact that's
why we're always going to need
literature
we're always going to need other things
like literature including
music and
art and philosophy and history
some of the other humanities as well
we're going to need film
these do in fact when they're doing
their job well deal with
these existential questions and they are
important
and they are difficult and they can
never be handled just by
say the natural or social sciences or by
management techniques
or as i mentioned putting together a
bunch of life hacks
people try to do that then they they
screw things up
right so literature is very
important at least the good parts of it
and then he says here's the mistake
therefore
literatures consider themselves the most
important
of people now who would be the
literatures it would be the creative
people who actually create literature
and would also be all the people who
talk about literature
we can talk about the literature world
people who
you know tell us what we should read and
why we should read it and
have podcasts and tv shows and all that
sort of stuff and he says
here's a metaphor for you a bank clerk
who's always handing money out
might as well consider himself a
millionaire just because you carry
around
james joyce and you know rapsode
about uh how great ulysses is which by
the way i don't think it's very
i don't i don't like ulysses myself but
um
you know people do talk about what what
a wonderful piece of literature this is
that doesn't mean you have anything in
common whatsoever with james joyce
the mere fact that you've been able to
run your eyes over the pages until you
got to the end of the book
doesn't mean that you actually
understood anything and even if you did
understand something
it might not be worth understanding you
might not have
figured out anything by doing that same
thing you could say for breeding
shustoff right i mean
maybe you should be a chest off yourself
so he says the high
estimate placed on unexplained unsolved
questions
aren't really to discredit writers in
our eyes and yet these literary men are
so clever
so cunning at stating their own case and
revealing the high importance of their
mission
in the long run they convince everybody
themselves most of all
and he says you know we could contrast
this to the roman
priests the augurs who had cut open you
know different
animals usually birds and then like make
you know predictions based on that
and cicero actually has one of these
people in on the nature of the gods book
three
uh talking about how they laugh while
they're doing this like look at these
stupid suckers
believing in this that organs would
reveal the future to them
and you know he says writers don't do
that instead
they um they lay their improbable
assertions before the public
and they have to be convinced in their
own minds otherwise they cannot begin
people come up with all sorts of crazy
stuff that allows them to
put their their ideas out there they
have to believe in those ideas right at
least to some degree
unless they're in on a grift all right
let's talk about tricks and
tropes and some advice that he gives
now this might be seen as rather cynical
he's making some observations about what
it is
that writers do and how it works
is he recommending it is he not
recommending it is he actually saying
that this is his own practice
i leave that to you to decide so he says
when a writer has to express this in in
chapter 40 of part one
when a writer has to express an idea
whose foundation he's not been able to
establish and which is yet dear to his
heart so that he earnestly wishes to
secure its general acceptance
as a rule he does he does this this is
the trick
he interrupts his exposition and makes a
small or at times a serious digression
during which he proves the invalidity of
this or that proposition often without
any reference to his real theme
having triumphantly exposed one or more
absurdities and thus acquired the aplomb
of the solid expert he returns to his
proper task
calculating that he will now inspire his
reader with greater confidence
and chestnut says well this is perfectly
justified this calculation
it's kind of a trick but this actually
works the reader is afraid to attack a
skilled dialectician
and prefers rather to agree than to risk
himself an
argument he says not even the greatest
intellects particularly in philosophy
disdain such stratagems people do this
all the time in their works and then you
know if you think about this
and then think about some of the things
you've read you will find
a lot of instances of that maybe even in
chest off himself
another great example if you want to get
people to
accept something and they don't already
accept it is to
we might say start off slow he says you
begin once
you begin your argument with inoffensive
commonplace assertions
we all agree that there is a world out
here right
there is something like a human nature
even if we don't know
what it is he says uh when suspicion has
been sufficiently lawed
and a certainty has been begot that what
follows will be a confirmation
of the reader's own accepted views then
has the moment arrived to speak one's
mind openly
now now you lay your cards on the table
but he says
in the same easy tone as if there were
no break in the flow of truisms the
logical connection is unimportant
consequence of manner and intonation is
much more impressive than consequence of
ideas
you go on in the same suave tone from
uttering a series of banalities
to expressing a new and dangerous
thought without any break if you succeed
in this the business is done
the reader will not forget the new words
will plague and torment
him until he has accepted them so this
is a
trick and again you can see many authors
doing this as well that's why we have
prefaces right
in the preface you say well we're doing
this and here's here's something
there will be some controversial ideas
in here but i'll be giving you some some
good reasons for it
and then you start you know start out
with some examples people love examples
and then
eventually you get to the point where
you're like well black is white
and then what how did we get here right
well
you know here's here's the argument for
it and then they're like
that can't possibly be true but in the
back of their mind
it's still working away the other thing
that he says that
is really it's one of the best things i
think chestnut
has ever come up with in terms of lines
is this thing about uh the police agents
and what does he mean by the police
agents morality
logic and science and he says the
writer's task is to go forward and share
impressions with a reader
he's not obliged to prove anything does
that mean he won't prove anything
no he will prove some things he'll make
some arguments
he'll make a case for things but the
case doesn't have to be particularly
good
because he's not really making the case
for the
attentive reader he's making it for
these
police agents because every step of his
progress is dogged by them
he has to have some sort of argument
with which to frustrate them
so that they then engage that instead of
like
you know going after him uh himself or
or herself or whatever so he says
there's no necessity to trouble too
deeply about the quality of
argumentation don't worry about being
inwardly right
it's enough if the reasoning which comes
handiest will succeed in
occupying those guardians of the verbal
highways
whose intention it is to obstruct his
passage
so you know for creative people they
don't have to be totally consistent they
don't have to make great arguments what
they have to do
is find things that have not been
articulated in that way
shape something out of the void and
that's difficult enough already
so you know they don't have to make it
to the best sellers list they don't have
to win
prizes all they have to do is follow out
the
requirements which are difficult enough
of creative
activity so very important theme again i
suggest that you think about some of the
examples that chester
provides and whether he himself is
following some of these insights and
guidelines that he's laying out
you